Welcome back everyoneit's Charlie, this will be my
new Spider-Manvs Kingpin video, we have Vincent D'Onofrio
talking about facing off with Spider-Man so
we'll break it all down and what the plan
is for all these characters for all the
movies in the Marvel Disney plus series
we do know a lot about what their plans are
for both Kingpin Daredevil and Tom Holland
Spider-Man I mean there's only one really
and gold and I think somebody just says
not Spider-Man Peter Parker so you guys have no
idea what you're in store for with born again
and I know there's a lot to unpack during that
clip so I'll explain what it all means if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there's a bunch of Spider-Man
related stuff happening really soon a bunch of
Daredevil and a bunch of Kingpin stuff happening
a lot of you probably asking does this mean the
Kingpin is going to be one of the villains in
Spider-Man 4 because we just found out that
Tom Holland resigned a new contract for his
next Trilogy and it's going to be more of a ground
level Trilogy in New York City Kingpin is probably
one of the biggest de facto ground level villains
in the MCU the way that they're setting him up
through Daredevil born again and does this mean
Spider-Man will show up in Daredevil born again
at some point because Vincent D'Onofriowas talking
about how Daredevil born again is going to blow us
away like those episodes are going to be crazy we
have no idea how good they're going to be and he
was saying it while he was talking about facing
off with Spider-Man you have questions yes I I
add a lot of questions I'm sure you had a lot of
questions but rest assured we're going to answer
them right now he is being a little bit of a hype
man like most actors are so here's the plan right
now for how all this plays out with those those
three characters Kingpin Daredevil and Spider-Man
if it wasn't clear during the events of Hawkeye
that series was meant to end around the Christmas
holiday the same Christmas that Spider-Man
no way home ends during so at the end of the
movie when he's in his new costume web slinging
through Rockefeller Center around the Christmas
tree that's meant to be around the same time the
Hawkeye was facing off with the tracksuit Bros
kingpins henchmen at the end of his series between
those series we had a pretty good idea for what
was going on with Daredevil and Kingpin at that
moment in the MCU even though Spider-Man no way
home takes place over the course of a couple
months Kingpin wasn't in control of the entire
city yet he had the tracksuit Bros but he was
still building his power base back the way Vincent
D'Onofrio explained it he's meant to be the same
version of Kingpin from the Daredevil Netflix
series even though they might retune a couple
things most of what they did during the Daredevil
Netflix episodes is meant to continue being Canon
talk about organized crime in the Marvel Universe
and you talk about the CD underbelly of New York
City there is one primary character that comes
from he said I want to bring you into the MCU and
I'm not going to say no to that like that's pretty
awesome I really love playing this character
I liked creating him you know from the art
of guys like David Mack Fisk is really driven by
emotion you know he's like a child and a monster
both at the same time so it got very intense
yesterday and got a little bit intense today too
so he's already faced off against Daredevil he's
already been to prison at least twice he confirmed
that he did not get snapped so he was around for
the five-year time Jump and that sort of changed
him fundamentally changed the way he operated
also being in prison after the events of Daredevil
season three so at the beginning of Hawkeye he was
still meant to be relatively small time compared
to what he will be by the end of Daredevil born
again we just saw Daredevil during the She-Hulk
episodes again and is pretty much business as
usual for him just continuing to protect his
City doing the Daredevil thing the reason why he
represented Spider-Man during Spider-Man no way
home was one because it was really cool Easter
egg but also because he helps a lot of superhero
characters the next big step of their Arc is
meant to happen during the echo episodes which
are supposed to come sometime later next year
and that's meant to be a direct continuation of
the events of echo versus Kingpin during the
Hawkeye series with Daredevil being a much
bigger character during that there have been talk
about having Daredevil inside the Hawkeye episodes
but they were already doing a lot with him in
Spider-Man no way home so that's why they just
saved having Daredevil and Kingpin in this same
series till later on when he comes back in the
Echo series it'll be a continuation of the comic
book Arc between the two of those characters at
the end of Hawkeye she winds up shooting him but
she only wounds him in the eye so he'll come back
being partially blinded because of his injuries
but then eventually heal it's right out of the
comics the big twist is that he comes back being
just like Daredevil like he can't see as Daredevil
can't see oh the irony during that series is
going to continue to build his power base Matt
Murdock Daredevil is going to be looking for
Jessica Jones I think they're supposed to tease
her actually coming back during Daredevil board
again like we'll hear Easter eggs for her during
the echo series both Daredevil and Kingpin will
be much bigger characters in the episodes than
they were during Hawkeye and Spider-Man no way
home or the She-Hulk episodes for that matter and
Vincent D'Onofrio said that the events of echo
directly lead into the beginning of Daredevil
born again which is supposed to start episodes at
the beginning of 2024 and based on the pace that
they're moving getting all these Productions
going it sounds like they're not going to get
Spider-Man 4 out till 2025 so it seems like the
events of devil born again which all take place
during 2024 will lead directly into Spider-Man 4.
during the Daredevil Born Again episodes they've
teased a bunch of the other Marvel Netflix
characters coming back they're supposed to
be 18 episodes so there's a lot of room for
cameos in introducing brand new characters
from the Daredevil Comics most notably Jessica
Jones coming back maybe Punisher maybe Luke
Cage as well too like all the Netflix actors said
that they want to come back it's just a matter of
scheduling and timing there's already been rumors
about them introducing other daredevil characters
from the comic story that there's 18 episodes so
there's going to be a bunch of characters but as
of right now one of the major arcs that they've
teased back a while ago was mayor Kingpin like
the whole idea through the course of the series
Kingpin will eventually run for and become mayor
of New York City like he did in the comics giving
him way more Authority making it easier for him
to change things around the city to suit his
purposes protect the city quote unquote like
Daredevil style protecting my city but in a very
dark rain Kingpin kind of way because of all the
teasers in Black Panther wakanda forever and some
of the other movies that are coming up there's
this very dark rain Vibe that's going on with the
movies in Marvel phase five like the Marvel secret
Invasion episodes are going to be the first big
Marvel series of next year and right after that
in the comics came dark rain because of what
happened during secret Invasion a lot of the
villains come to power and use that against the
heroes they just confirmed that Val is the new
Nick Fury type of character with her hands and all
kinds of pies in a bad way though like a darker
kind of Nick Fury orchestrating a lot of shady
stuff she's the current head of the CIA wields
enormous power they just recast Harrison Ford as
Thunderbolt Ross for the events of Captain America
4 in the Thunderbolts movie those are going to be
coming at the end of Marvel Phase 5 and supposedly
during that he's going to become the president
of the United States and it's supposed to be a
bit of a riff on the Norman Osborne dark rain Arc
in the comics really shady person either outright
villain or anti-hero depending on how you look
at him taking a position of great power in all
the other Heroes just having to find a way to
deal with that like how do you fight the U US
president if you're Captain America for instance
if all the villains like Kingpin for instance make
themselves seem like Heroes to the people and
the heroes like Daredevil going against them
would seem like villains they started to do
a version of this during Daredevil season 3
on Netflix when Kingpin cultivated this image
of himself in the public eye as a hero but was
trying to use Bullseye wearing Daredevil's costume
to discredit him make the public think of him as
a villain he didn't come close to being mirror
at that time but that was before the events of
Avengers Infinity War before he's changed his Mo
supposedly they take that idea one step further
during the events of Daredevil born again and
because he's such a big Force controlling New York
City in such a big way it makes sense that by the
time Spider-Man 4 comes around he would encounter
him at some point while he's busy saving people
around the city fighting other Spider-Man specific
villains through Spider-Man 4 5 and 6 during his
new Trilogy I don't know how long they planned
to continue the Kingpin Arc with him staying in
power in New York City because it'll take them
at least like eight or nine years to get that next
Spider-Man trilogy out so live action Spider-Man
and versus Kingpin in the MCU might happen sooner
rather than later but given Marvel's treatment of
the Spider-Man character with all the Marvel
Disney plus Series so far like talking about
what's actually happening during Daredevil born
again what's happening with Spider-Man the next
couple of years my early Theory right now is
that Tom Holland Spider-Man doesn't appear
during Daredevil Born Again Marvel and Sony had
just been really weird about what they do with
Tom Holland's Spider-Man character like they
referenced Spider-Man a lot and other stuff but
you don't see Tom Holland himself showing up in a
lot of those Disney plus series for instance they
had like a completely different actor playing
Spider-Man during the what if series it wasn't
Tom Holland doing the voice another really good
example is the Spider-Man freshman year series
that's going to be coming in a couple years during
that series Charlie Cox and Vincent D'Onofrio are
going to be playing their characters facing off
with a version of Spider-Man but it will not be
played by Tom Hahn they're treating it like a
Multiverse Series so that version of Spider-Man
will be from a different universe and what
they'll probably do in the MCU is just save
any kind of actual Face-Off between Spider-Man
and Vincent D'Onofrio Kingpin for Spider-Man 4
for Spider-Man 5 or some point during his
Trilogy so when Vincent D'Onofriois saying
that their ultimate goal is to Face Off Spider-Man
against Kingpin he's basically talking about way
down the line and also that's just part of what
they're setting up like that's not gonna be the
whole thing that they do during Spider-Man
4 and you shouldn't expect Spider-Man to be
like a really big part of Daredevil born again
I would be blown away if he does have some kind
of Cameo scene during that but I'm not going
to hold my breath for that Sony and Marvel are
still getting along like they'll still continue
working together making movies together per the
Sony president and Kevin feige but they can get
kind of weird about the other characters too and
what happens with Tom Hall and Spider-Man like oh
you want to use him in all your Disney plus series
well you gotta let us use Spider-Man and all of
our Spider-Man spin-off movies too pray that I
don't alter the deal further everybody getting
Darth Vader vibes from Sony but everybody let
me know in the comments when do you want to see
Spider-Man Actually face off against the version
of Kingpin if it's not going to happen for at
least a couple years my next big video will be
for the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
post-credits scene I'll do a full Easter egg
and breakdown video That's supposed to air on
Friday B sure to watch it as soon as possible
everyone click here to learn about the secret
Deadpool Christmas movie that Ryan Reynolds made
and click here to learn all about the century
coming to the MCU in Marvel Thunderbolts movie
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!